señor gum binner gracias por esta
comunicación es una estrategia política
esta salida tan rápida de donald trump
del hospital
bueno les es muy difícil decir en este
momento cuánto de esto ha sido un 70 y
médico y cuánto ha sido un incidente
político lo que es claro es que este va
a tener un gran impacto en la campaña
que falta apenas un mes para terminar
antes de salir lo mencionábamos el
mandatario envió un mensaje en twitter
diciendo que no tengan miedo al cob y 19
esto hace que se fortalezca de cara a
las elecciones del próximo noviembre
tras esta enfermedad
puede tener un aspecto positivo y
negativo para el presidente por el lado
positivo él está tratando de mostrar su
carácter fuerte que él puede recuperar
rápidamente a esta enfermedad tan serio
y quiere compararlo con lo que él está
tratando de pintar a iovine como alguien
viejo y davis pero por otro lado es
claro que el público estadounidense no
está contento con el liderazgo del
presidente trump con la pandemia
entonces mientras la pandemia está en
los titulares eso es un negativo
políticamente para todos el presidente
quiere enfocar en la economía quiere
enfocar la batalla para la corte suprema
quiere enfocar las las protestas en las
calles que son violentos pero no quiere
que el coaching sea el tema principal
mientras el kobe domina los titulares
está en peligro la presidencia y la
campaña de qom